elle se distingue en basket handball
elles sont décidés à briller dans un
sport plus particulièrement réservé aux
garçons
le football début des années 70 pas
facile pour des footballeuses de se
faire une place dans ce monde encore
très masculin
pourtant il ya bien une équipe féminine
qui va bouleverser les codes à la fin
des années 60
c'est le stade de reims une équipe créée
en 1968 par un homme le journaliste
pierre geoffroy
qu'est ce qui vous a pris c'est à
l'occasion d'un d'une organisation une
sorte de kermesse qui avait lieu chaque
année et on cherchait une petite
attraction
alors on a respecté un peu parmi les
sportifs de reims finalement ça suscité
un engouement assez intéressant l'idée
un peu folle de pierre geoffroy va
pourtant populariser le football féminin
en 1971
l'équipe de france féminine participe à
une coupe du monde non officielle au
mexique
elle est presque entièrement composé de
rémoise trois ans plus tard un
championnat et même créer grâce à ses
joueuses
rencontre avec l'une d'elles ghislaine
soit capitaine de l'équipe en 1977
jj la capitaine des rémoises a débuté
comme gardien de but elle joue
maintenant avant centre et se défend de
pratiquer un sport viril
non je pense pas vous voyez je suis
marié j'ai une vie familiale très très
heureuse et je n'ai pas de problème et
jutras fille
et oui il est possible d'être une fille
est de jouer au football
malgré tout les préjugés persistent mais
le club a remporté cinq fois le titre de
champion de france entre 1975 et 1982 en
1978 elle se préparait pour une
compétition en chine footballeur et
globe trotter il ne manquait
pratiquement rémoise qu'un voyage en
chine pour boucler leur long périple
autour du monde depuis la création de
leur équipe
il y a dix ans déjà qu'elle foule tous
les terrains de france et de l'hexagone
permettant au football féminin de se
développer et de progresser chaque année
vers la perfection grâce aux pionnières
du stade de reims
le football féminin est de plus en plus
pris au sérieux
pourtant 1992 tout s'écroule pour les
filles du stade de reims
mais là messieurs bonjour le stade de
reims est mort en fin de matinée le
tribunal de grande instance de reims a
décidé sa liquidation judiciaire
finalement la section féminine est
relancée en 2014 après le retour de
l'équipe masculine parmi l'élite
en 2018 le journal de france 2 retrouvez
ghislaine souef capitaine à l'époque et
toujours avant gardiste dans l'âme
ça m'a permis de comprendre la vie
c'était une école si et champenoise
compte cinq titres de champion de france
elles pourront tenter d'en rajouter un
sixième l'an prochain en 2019
elles ont validé leur montée en première
division avant peut-être de connaître la
gloire comme leurs aînés